our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us and
this morning
we introduce you to two people along
with some young volunteers who are
trying to make sure
their california community does not go
hungry
the group feeding america estimates that
the economic fallout from the pandemic
may leave more than 54 million americans
that is texas and florida combined and
then some 54 million
struggling to regularly feed their
families this year jonathan vigliotti
shows us now how people in one los
angeles community
are coming together to help their
neighbors
these days the parking lot at the wood
cafe in los angeles
is often empty unless
it's a sunday i'm serving and feeding
more people now than i would be if i was
open in restaurants
dimitrios mavromicholis was forced to
temporarily close his business back in
march because of covet 19.
but then he got a call from an old
friend and former employee
natalie flores i said hey what are you
doing with that
with your restaurant he's like well
actually i had to lay off all my
employees
and it was just like dang
every week the two transformed the
restaurant
into a food drive with a drive-through
to help those struggling during the
pandemic
flores got the idea for nourish la after
seeing families
asking for help on social media they're
on their last hundred dollars or
less and they had no food to eat what
went through your mind when you read
those things
i was really upset and i was really
frustrated because
we shouldn't have that problem straight
from the farm pomegranates the group
collects donations from local farms
food banks and grocery stores volunteers
then pack
bags with everything from high quality
produce and meats to freshly baked bread
and flowers nine-year-old kalia jade
salvador
is one of the youngest volunteers seeing
these families sometimes can make me
feel sad
many people but once we are able to feed
them it makes
me more happy that we can actually give
them something
for you the kids and the youth are
really the catalyst for
uh driving this thing forward
i feel like i should keep coming back i
feel like
i have a duty to almost and he said too
on the day we visited the organization
fed more than 1200 people
hal hyatt was first in line i admire
them that they
they do they they do this they take out
their own time and
they don't get paid retired teacher
linda scott used to rely on income from
housing foreign students
until clovit19 shut that down you ever
imagined you'd find yourself in a
situation like absolutely not you know
i'm 72
so who would have thought i am grateful
that you know that we have this and
people
really care about it the problem is that
this issue doesn't discriminate food
hunger is
all around us and we can refuse to see
it or we could
go head on and really love our neighbors
without judgment so we got more bread
coming out you guys
flores and mavro michalish now hope to
inspire similar food drives across the
nation
with neighbors feeding neighbors and
nourishing the soul
how much longer do you think you can do
this before you say
i need the kind of help that i'm
offering people right now
you know what i thought well at some
point it'll dry up and right now it
hasn't it just keeps going and i said i
can't stop this now
i can't because
it's changed for cbs this morning
jonathan bigliotti los angeles i thought
that was such a good question jonathan
asked how long do you think you can do
this before you realize you know i need
help too
yes i agree he's deeply affected by
knows the difference he's making
it's moved him yeah it's a moving thing
to do i'm thinking about that federal
stimulus we could use another round in
this country
you know i was thinking the bread looked
really good
one with some butter melting just saying